one of the things that I've been
realizing as a consequence of going
through these stories is that the degree
to which they're about individuals is
quite remarkable and I think that's
really telling you know one of the
reasons I prefer Dostoevsky to Tolstoy
is because Tolstoy is more of a
sociologist he's more interested in the
relationship between groups of people
this is an oversimplification because
obviously told stories a great author
but I'd like to us dsq better because he
really delves into the souls of
individuals and I think it's remarkable
the degree to which all of the stories
that we've covered so far in Genesis are
about individuals and they're quite
realistic which is quite remarkable -
they're not really romanticized to any
great degree because all of the people
that are regard as regarded let's say as
patriarchal or matriarchal figures in
Genesis have no shortage of ethical
different no shortage of ethical flaws
and also no shortage of difficulties in
their life and the difficulties are
realistic there they're major-league
problems you know like familial
catastrophes and famine and war and
revenge and hatred and all those things
it's not a it's not a pretty it's not a
pretty book and that's one of the things
that makes it great I mean that's one of
the things that characterizes great
literature right is that it doesn't
present you with a whitewashed view of
humanity or of existence and that's
really a relief I think because as you
all know because you're alive there's no
such thing as a whitewash existence like
you're to be alive is to be in trouble
ethically and existentially I've been
reading this book recently I'll talk
about it a little bit later it's called
better never to have a bean and it was
written by a philosopher in South Africa
in Cape Town named Benatar that's his
last name and he basically argues
I think it's a specious argument and I
think it's artificially constructed but
he basically argues that
because life is so full of suffering
even good lives are very much full of
suffering that it's wrong to bring
children into the world because the
suffering outweighs the good even in
good lives and it's actually wrong it
would also be better not to exist for
exactly the same reason and my sense in
reading the book is that he came to that
conclusion and then wrote the book to
justify it which is actually the reverse
of the way that you should write a book
what you should do when you're writing a
book is you should have a question and
you should it should be a real question
right it should be one you don't know
the answer to and then you should be
studying and writing like mad and
reading everything you can get your
hands on to see if you can actually
grapple with the problem and come to
some solution and you should walk the
reader as well through your process of
thinking so that they can come to the
well not necessary to the same
conclusion but at least track what
you're doing and I don't think that's
what he did I think he wrote it
backwards but then and so I was thinking
about it a lot because that's actually a
question that I've contended with in my
writing there are Memphis toe Philly and
our satanic figures for example in girth
is Faust and also Ivan in that in the
brothers karamasoff
who basically make the same case you
know that existence is so rife with
trouble and suffering that it would be
better if it didn't exist at all and the
problem I've had with that there's a
variety of them but one of the problems
I've had with that is what happens if
you start to think that way because what
I've observed is that people who begin
to think that way that isn't where they
stop like that they get angry at
existence which is what happened to Cain
as we saw in the Cain and Abel story and
then the next step is to start taking
revenge against existence and that
cascades until it's revenge against well
I think the best way of thinking about
it is revenge against God for the crime
of being which is I think the deepest
sort of hatred that you can entertain
and and and when you're in the grip of a
really deep emotion like a really
profound emotion right at the bottom of
emotions you're in something that's like
a quasi-religious state and that's more
or less independent of your beliefs a in
a transcendent deity
I mean you can be in a profoundly
emotional state that's as deep as it can
be and it can have religious
significance without that necessarily
signifying anything about a transcendent
being you know but but then I was
thinking you see the problem with that
argument is you can gerrymander it
endlessly you know because first of all
how do you measure suffering and how do
you measure happiness it's like how do
you assign weights to them and god
there's just no way of doing that you
have to do it arbitrarily and so you can
make an argument that the suffering
outweighs the happiness you just wait
the suffering more heavily than you wait
the happiness and that's the end of that
you know and so that's that's a problem
but I think there's a deeper problem